hello everyone welcome to the last
session slot of the day you guys have
been so good all day listening to lots
and lots of talks now it's my turn and I
of course get to say the classic phrase
I'm the person standing between you and
beer so I'm not gonna promise to be
brief because beer won't be served until
after the last session anyway so you're
stuck with me this is a new topic I'm a
little bit excited about this topic I've
never presented this topic before I hope
that it's gonna go you know well guess
I'll see outside but if you know there's
a party tonight find me with a beer
preferably and we'll talk about it and
tell me what you know what's good or not
so good it's gonna be fun because this
is a very ambitious title right it's
like practical design patterns in the
nature very ambitious it could might as
well be called Magnus rants about cloud
for 60 minutes that's that's like it
could be that because it's the same
thing really because I'm I have some
perspectives on this and I'm going to
share them with you so in the cloud
right you have all the opportunities of
succeeding of doing great things and to
fail in all the old ways plus some new
ones right and in the cloud you can
deploy anything anywhere at any time and
the topic we're not going to talk much
about today is this
in fact this word works like a little
Incan tation you have to always say it
three times okay
preferably maybe click your heels as
well for a good measure but you have to
say automation automation automation
otherwise it won't work okay just so you
know if it doesn't work that's why you
didn't say it right anyways in the cloud
you have this unlimited compute power
until you get your credit card
statements so there are reasons why we
want to do this well I want to start by
asking you guys this is I know I'm not
such a but this is from Bill old I think
the audience
do you have something deployed into a
cloud which is in production hands up
that is a large portion of this room
that's I would say it's a majority of
the room which is very interesting
that number keeps going up so I have
been around the cloud for a good long
time I started out when they announced I
was fortunate to be in the audience when
they announced Windows Azure that's a
PDC conference in 2006 and I went home
from there immediately and I've been
spoken talking about cloud public
speaking about cloud since then and I've
been working with cloud since then so it
means that I have done this more than a
decade and that's that feels great now
when everything from Microsoft is a sure
all the products that don't actually
have a show in the name they rename them
to something a sure right so it's cool I
was the first one to become an MVP for
Azure in the Nordic countries so I was
there from the beginning and I'm also
what Microsoft call a Regional Director
which is a little bit funny because I
don't work at Microsoft I run my own
company lofty soft that's my company I
don't work for Microsoft I don't have a
region and I don't direct anything but
it's it's it means that I'm a buddy of
Microsoft I hang out with them and and
we have not so fun together I actually
get to talk to Microsoft more on a VP
level which is so cool thing I like to
do has anyone participated in a global
Asha boot camp anyone this one just one
oh my god just one that's great because
there's probably going to be some global
Asha boot camp locations here in
Australia for this year every year we do
this and I'm one of the people that kind
of hang out and and and sort of
administrate I don't take credit for
what all the great work that all
community leaders around the world do
but I believe it was around two hundred
and eighty something locations more than
15,000 attending last year and at this
global and when event we do hashtag
global Asher and that's trending around
the world it's fantastic so we're gonna
do that again this year and we will
announce there I said I was going to
ignite right so I'm going to ignite
after in fact tomorrow and we will
announce at ignite when the date will be
for global Azure boot camp for the next
version I kind of have to talk about
that right it's it's a thing it's I love
doing community stuff around the world
just to set expectations about this talk
as talking about I told you about
ranting right I used the term pattern
very loosely here it's not very strict
at all I will talk strictly about so
here's a pattern and here's what we did
with that pattern to you know help us
with our really thing we built but I'm
also going to talk about other things
so really it's it's good to know about a
sure advice dispensed by one who was
there but you know what they say about
advice right advice is a form of
nostalgia dispensing it is a way of
fishing it out from the past from the
disposal wiping it off painting over the
ugly parts and recycling it for more
than it's worth so that's what I'm going
to do now basically it looks like you're
migrating to the cloud would you like
some help with that
I think every presentation has to have
Clippy don't you I think he does has to
be here but this is what the cloud looks
like and I use this as an old slide
Microsoft to stop using this slide but I
keep it as sort of to give you a picture
right this this kind of a slide whenever
you see that it's supposed to give you
the impression that oh my gosh there's a
lot it's even an old slide it's it says
36 Asha regions it's like 52 now right
and growing or some 54 I don't know it
just keeps growing more and more Asha
regions but this slide is supposed to
give you this Wow okay there's so many
services in the Azure platform I can't
believe it and yes that's true so I I
figure it we figure out how many how
many are there right now that's a little
larger there's a very very simple way to
find out you just have to go to Asher
and say Asher I'd like you to get me all
the providers that I can use oh I just
you just saw the number anyway they're
all the providers it's a long list as
most of them are from Microsoft
Microsoft dot something but they're a
bunch of providers that are not
Microsoft providers here you're clouding
dynaTrace and and things and then let's
figure out how many there are and I
already showed you there's a hundred and
fifty resource providers in Azure and
some of them have multiple services so
there's plenty
things in the Azure platform lots and
growing that number keeps going up
hundred and fifty is a good round number
but they're not stopping there and
there's more coming so that's how much
there is and now it's time for a little
check-in here
how many can identify this architecture
what are we deploying when we deploy
this you know what is this yes
Oh true but there's a special there I
was okay I'll be clear there's a special
service in Asscher which they showed
Microsoft showed with this architecture
anyone know this is a cloud service this
was the first thing you could deploy in
Azure when they announced Windows Azure
was a platform service called a cloud
service it's a very simple thing you had
a load balancer and some web roles and
if you wanted to have background workers
you would spin up other servers to do
that job and then the only way actually
initially the only way to communicate
between the two was to encourage and
have the worker DQ them and work on them
that was it that was basically this is a
sure right when it was announced we've
come quite far since then let's put it
that way for instance now you know we
have web apps app services that you can
deploy those are great do you know by
chance what they run upon so in case you
didn't know that
Microsoft runs scores of machines lots
and lots of servers running on the cloud
service deployment and they use that
deployment to then allow you to
provision your web applications onto
these boxes that's how it works I'm just
saying pretty cool now I'm going to
start with a bit of a rant I'm going to
start to talk about the thing that
people always do last and mostly get
wrong or don't do it all and it's not
really a pattern but maybe it's the best
practice that I could like give you if
any advice at all and that is to take a
look at this guy as your monitor the
last thing people do is like okay so now
we have this serve now it runs we've
deployed it we're in production it works
seems to be at a bit of a snafu here
let's see if we can figure out what it
does and yeah then you haven't really
thought about or most people right not
you sorry most people either people who
are not in this room they would have
thought you know and we can add
monitoring and diagnostics and that
stuff later right we'll do it later no
problem that's the problem so the thing
about Asher is that it is a measured
service and what do I mean when I say
that well obviously if you use it you
pay for it you're gonna get a very
granular bill every month you know this
right it says specifically exactly how
many bits and bytes and CPU cycles and
here's the charge for that right exactly
so that doesn't sound good but it is
it's very good what's your response if
somebody measures you a lot what do you
do you also measure you that's what you
do there's a great quote which I want to
want you to guys to have from dr. H
James Harrington that I love which is
the perfect quote for this this space
measurement is the first step that leads
to control and eventually to improvement
you can't if you can't measure something
you can't understand it if you can't
understand that you can't control it and
if you can't control it you can't
improve it or as the Taylor's put so you
want to float over that
go for it and as that as the Taylor puts
it you measure twice then cut right
that's how you do it except most people
don't do it that way I've seen so many
clients and scenarios you can't believe
I have come in to cut like a customer I
was there I told him about Asher and I
showed them stuff and now yeah we're
gonna build stuff going away Magnus and
they called me a couple of years later
and they literally asked me what are we
gonna do we have a performance problem
customers say the service is slow and
I'm like okay how slow and they're like
oh well we don't exactly measure that
okay why are we having this conversation
so in Azure Microsoft is putting a lot
of emphasis on what the thing they call
the let's go to Azure
here we are in Azure a lot of emphasis
on the thing that they call the yeah I
want it to be full screen I like full
screen there we go
emphasis on this thing called monitor I
put it up top it's like a little
speedometer thing a little gauge you
click on that and you come into monitor
okay
so Microsoft is putting a lot of
emphasis on this they're trying to pull
together or they are not trying they are
in fact pulling together all kinds of
things logs and metrics one place for
you to configure all of your alerts and
things if you never have been on this
page you're not doing it right I'm sorry
to say but you have to be on this page
when you're doing a sure and then here's
a bunch of the getting started tutorials
and demos and all these things and I
come off as a bad you know as a poor
sales rep for Microsoft when I talk like
this I I realize it but I don't care I
cannot tell you like there's always the
scenario that people don't measure well
they don't measure nearly as well as
they have as they could and and
basically that's my first rant okay I
think I might leave that now but I think
I hope you get the picture here how
important monitoring really is every
service in Azure has diagnostic settings
have you turned them all on at all most
people do not they don't even know how
to turn them on okay the Diagnostics is
there but they're not using them so when
I work with all kinds of companies small
large what unites them is that they want
to go to a sure in some way shape or
form a couple of things that I've you
know picked up here in terms of good
practices when we're talking about the
monitoring angle you should apply the
principle of least privilege as in don't
let everyone just roam around your
services and change things because you
will be very confused about which is
sending Diagnostics to what and that is
that can be mitigated by simply not
letting anyone in there's a good setting
called a reader give that to everyone
everyone can see what you're doing but
no nobody can change stuff
that's a good setting only basically
only the the deployment server is
allowed to deploy things that would be
cool
most people are not that strict but it's
a good thing to be and then of course
you have this monitoring capability you
get all the data pulled into just one
place and anything that you can find in
the monitoring in the Diagnostics in the
logs if it's a performance counter if
it's you know anything that you can find
in there you can make an alert on so you
find something wrong well then you can
go and configure some alerts on that and
that can call a web hook that can call
send you an email or a text message or
whatever it is that's what really
important you do so I and I already said
for every diagnostic service there is a
set there for every service there is a
diagnostic setting and and the last one
is actually incredibly important many
times it's like the IT department are
doing their thing and they're deploying
stuff and they're you know putting up
into setting up new services and oh we
need a new environment and they're doing
that and I'm sure they're doing all
things really really thoroughly but
there's no one with a budget
responsibility they're basically all of
that IT stuff is just a cost and then
what happens much much later the bean
counters the men in suits or women in
dresses or whatever that is they come
running right they go like okay so um
this a sure thing we're spending about a
hundred thousand dollars a month on this
now could you maybe please tell me what
is it that we're spending it on and it's
it's getting much right it's getting
expensive
so what you should be doing which is a
difficult place to come to is to make
somebody a person it's always Dave but
you know Dave bloody Dave make somebody
responsible it doesn't have to be a
person could be a team lead or somebody
but it could also be like the whole team
is responsible for it but anyway at the
end of the day there needs to be a
budget that needs to be a number because
otherwise people are not super
interested or focused on how well the
services we deploy actually perform on
the resources that we have deployed and
when they don't perform well what
gonna do they're gonna add more services
they're gonna add more cost if there is
somebody with a budget responsibility
that somebody will say hey wait a minute
maybe we spend some time actually making
the code better you know figuring out if
we can run this on fewer instances and
what's the only way to figure out if we
can run it on fewer instances implement
monitoring aha
so that's actually super important
figure that right all right
so rant it took a long time to rant
about that I'm not not even sorry not in
the least but let's talk about a pattern
let's go real pattern now okay that's
why you're here the throttle pattern
super important so Microsoft pictures is
like this and I'm gonna say like you
need to spend some time to decipher this
picture I don't think it's very good so
we'll put it in you know parentheses I'm
sure we can figure out something better
here
I'll give you an example we had an
example of an API that we had had let
Partners use our API and so they were
able to call our API actually to send
emails and normally we send about 200 to
500 emails per day in that range so
small small number of emails and then we
had a spike we had a really bad abuser
guy who sent over 300,000 emails in a
matter of a few hours and the problem
with that was that first of all he
stopped all of the other legitimate
legitimate emails from going out and
effectively gave us a production level
dose attack so our emailing service was
was disengaged we had to go and and
unravel all of that the one thing that
was funny though a little bit of a
payback was that he sent himself so many
emails that he brought his own email
server down at the company and they
started to refusing his emails and he
got in a lot of trouble internally at
his company were like yes
that's awesome but you know bottom line
is that we were getting blacklisted
email servers around the world they
didn't like us anymore because you know
we're apparently we're spammers so
that's terrible which means that you
have to understand that if you have an
API that somebody can use they will
abuse it it will happen it's just a
matter of time so any when any any time
that you have something like that you
should be definitely defensive and
implement there's a classic pattern
throttle you implement it so that you're
able to say hey wait a minute you have
sent 800 emails today no more that's it
right some way to stop this and you know
if you haven't put this in your code yet
it's only a matter of time before that
will happen to you the thing that
happened to us right so please don't go
there take this or heed this advice and
definitely when you when this happens to
you collect data on this abuse so that
you can have numbers we were able to
send pretty detailed screenshots we
didn't collect that we learned as well
we didn't collect it the right way but
we were able to send pretty detailed
screenshots with the email addresses he
was trying to send to we were able to
open up the emails from our end
furgus they bounced back right and when
they bounced back they came back and we
could see the message because it had
bounced right so we could see that he
was sending him himself debug messages
through our mail system which is I don't
know hundreds of thousands what are you
doing but it was good evidence to have
when we sent it back to to the company
that you know they were all ashamed
actually for for having done such a
thing to us but implement a switch so
that you can maybe selectively turn
switch off abusers if you can remove
them right then you're in a good place
you can say that okay Dave no more
there's no email going out Dave you've
sent enough that's that's something that
you should consider specifically when
you're talking about somebody else who
will you know interact with you
they will interact with you in in lots
of a very fantastic ways that you never
thought that they would and this is
going to happen or or in fact there's a
service for that in a sure it doesn't
hit every scenario but you could go in
and use the service API management it is
in Azure some people feel it's a little
pricey and you kind of have to fit there
or hit the sweet spot really if you do
that then you could you know if it's a
match
- well consider using it I've used it
sometimes but I've discarded it other
times depends but the whole point of
that is that it's it acts as a gateway
in front of your in front of your
service you have your service somewhere
it doesn't have to be in Azure so long
as it can so long as this API management
can see it your service can be
on-premise but the general gist of it
all is that this is a place where you
can throttle you can put out for your
for application developers that are
going to use your service they can
subscribe to it and you can charge
through this service as well and you can
give them a rate this is how much you
can use the api per day or whatever that
is and and if they want to have more
they pay a higher premium so that works
really well
just as a side tip maybe you don't have
to write that code to implement the
throttle and implement that stuff
yourself maybe it's already built right
it's always a good thing to do check if
it's already built but let's go simpler
let's go to some of the very powerful
fundamentals some very powerful basics
that I really like for instance storage
patterns this might be my favorite
pattern of all patterns because it in
its its simplicity it's brilliant so if
you have an application and that
application needs to fetch some data you
can go to the data store wherever it is
data base something and fetch the data
it might be that it needs to like
collect that you make a query or
something and that's gonna take it's a
shared resource and that's gonna take
power away from that that service right
another way to do it if it's well-known
views and things that you want to look
at is to materialize those views in a
separate store like you could put that
in an Asscher table or a JSON blob or
something like that materialized to view
somewhere else and whenever you know
maybe there's a reasonable tolerance for
when the data needs to be updated so
people are changing the data changing
the data and you know from time to time
you go and an update of those views
however often you need to do it I don't
know but a really good scenario here is
to distribute yes the next one is sort
of connected to this the idea here is
that you could use this to distribute
data around the world there is another
pattern sort of closely related to this
first one called static content hosting
pattern if you have static content of
you could you know be reasonably static
if it's not updated super often making
it a static piece of content is fine but
then you have really static content like
CSS files and images and all these
things those are very static of course
but when you do with the static content
hosting pattern is that you remove that
all of that static content from your
application you don't host it inside of
your application right you host it
outside of your application on a
separate storage that can help you when
you want to deploy something around the
world so I had this gentleman come up to
me what I was doing was ask the experts
at tech days Sweden two years ago this
gentleman comes up to me says we have
business in Europe and Australia and we
want to run this service that has a you
know a bunch of data that we need to
read and and and also update and he was
showing me his architecture and we
talked through his architecture how he
was going to synchronize databases
between Europe and Australia and you
know files and things and it was really
it wasn't that complicated but it was it
was nice he had thought about it and he
was excited and was his baby and he
wanted to like okay can we let's talk
about this architecture is it good
yeah it's good it's fine you're gonna do
well I have maybe an option for you and
that is to consider maybe how much are
you reading your data and how much are
you updating and interviewed him and
same as most they don't update the data
all that much but they query it a lot
okay then I think we have an option here
so we wound up actually doing exactly
the materialized view pattern for them
we did it a little bit more
sophisticated than that but the point is
that he was able to materialize views
for all the querying both in Australia
and in Europe and whenever an update
could would come in it would update the
database which they actually placed in
Europe and instead of synchronizing
databases you just had to have one
database and so there were more costs
but basically just by having an
architectural conversation about this
were able to take down his cost and his
complexity in his solution quite a bit
instead so we went and implemented this
command query responsibility segregation
pattern and that's a reasonably
complicated beast to deal with it kind
of looks like this the the gist of it is
that you separate querying from from
commands so any updates go in a
different direction and all the query
and go up here and what happens when you
have a command is that you write it to
the real storage but you also write it
to some views that you have updated so
the views can be queried quickly and the
real storage the database is holds the
actual truth so that's what that's what
that is and basically there's a lot of
talk about this pattern I don't know if
you've heard about it before but I
basically think it's the teenage sex of
contemporary software architecture and
you know what something is when you say
it's like teenage sex right it's like
you very few people are doing it and
those and and and all everybody is
talking about it but those who are doing
it or not doing it right so so really
that's what that's what it is and and
it's not simple this is very complicated
so I said we were going to talk about
something simple right storage patterns
and I give you this that it's not very
simple so there are a couple of options
there as well and I'm gonna
unfortunately come back to sounding like
a cell so
things from for Microsoft I really don't
but the sequel database service has
built-in geo replication right so if you
wanted to handle all of that data
synchronization stuff you can have a
master database say in Europe and you
update that master database from based
on on changes that you put on a cure or
a service but message bus or something
similar and it's going to automatically
synchronize to another database for you
you can synchronize to for other
databases so you can have a total of
five geographically spread out doesn't
hit every scenario I understand that but
if it does how helpful this literally is
pointing click on the map in the portal
you say hey I have my database here in
Europe I want to have in Australia click
Save and synchronize increasing trends
ok well that's cool additionally
Microsoft has another one right Cosmos
DB it's pretty cool I mean that is a
really cool database Multi multi API so
that you can connect to it and bunch of
things I'm certainly not going to go
into detail on it but one thing that
they are working on now they'd still in
preview there's a big conference next
week maybe it'll go GA I really honestly
don't know but it's multi master support
in that one which means that if you have
your application into regions say Europe
and Australia again you will have the
the database in two regions I'm not
really sure why this picture shows to
here but you will have the database as
well in both regions and automatically
you can do reads and writes locally to
that database they will be synchronized
you can do reads and writes to that one
and they will be synchronized
automatically automatic synchronization
multi master and it's pretty spectacular
of course you're paying for twice as
many databases but all the
synchronization all that stuff it just
happens you don't have to think about it
ever so that can help if you know that
these services exist you might be able
to use them right another one
and this picture is a little weird as
well I mean what is what is with all of
this whiteness here it's all the picture
I think we'll have to put that in
parentheses as well
it's the valet key pattern this is a
really cool and useful pattern you know
valet of course super do you do that a
lot in Australia valet parking
you do they do it a lot in the states
right all everywhere and we don't do
that in Sweden okay
valet parking anyway of course as you
all know works in such a way that you
drive up to their restaurant or whatever
you're going to you hand your keys to
somebody in the park some parks is for
you and that's the point you could give
them your real key to the car but we've
seen all seen the movies right they go
like joyriding with your car and
drifting and stuff right we don't want
that so instead of giving the real key
there is a valet key as anyone have won
a valet key a special other key that you
can give to the the parking attendant
which only allows them to drive a very
short distance then the car will stop
automatically so that's that's what that
is and how that works and it's a special
key for a special purpose right is a
restricted key and and how does that
valet pattern come into play here in a
really good way it turns out when you
have the scenario you want to send files
to the service or receive files from the
service what you really shouldn't be
doing is pushing those bits through the
service you should go to the Asscher
storage direct and there's a there's a
response I'm going to describe this in
detail HTTP 302 found that is a good
response that's your friend so I'm going
to show you how this works
the valet key in annasher they're called
shared access signature have you used
them yep yeah several people very good
this is brilliant so here's here's a
file that I have in blob storage and if
I go to a sure and browse to this file
I've already done that in ahead of time
here if I browse to my file
I'll show you this file in block
storage it comes back and says actually
it says 404 literally what it is saying
is that we're we're not gonna tell you
if that file exists because you don't
have access to it and I'm not gonna say
if it's there or not so you get a 404
now what you could do to access this
file is you could go into this container
in Azure and you could set the public
access level and make it public but then
the file would be publicly available for
everyone right sometimes that's cool but
other times maybe it's not so what you
then can do is to generate this shared
access signature let's take it from
yesterday it's always good to go back oh
that's last year it's always good to go
back a little because of you know
potentially clock drift and things like
that
this file will be available until
tomorrow I won't read access you can see
how I can set readwrite delete whichever
one you want and you create this
signature I'll copy the query string
there and I'll have a notepad ready so
then I'll paste it for you and just
quickly zoom in you get this query
string thing this is the key it says
here what it's valid for and it's also
signed at the end so if I take that key
and I attach it to the end of our zoom
in the end of our URL here if I do that
paste it in there and browse to it
I'll get unicorn rainbow butterfly
kitten right I think everybody needs to
have unicorn rainbow butterfly kittens
in their lives so you're welcome right
and this file is now accessible with
this key if I were to go and change
anything in the key could you see it's
signed if I changed the three to a four
there or I think actually supposed to be
42 right and it's unauthenticated right
the key is broken so it's signed you can
change it and that's the valet key how
it comes into effect and several
multiple services in Azure use this
approach and why is that important when
it comes to storage again so I'm gonna
walk you through how you can do what you
what you can do
to use storage for what it's for not
only storing files but also actually
sending and retrieving files okay
so here's how you would do it if you
wanted to upload a file I have a client
somewhere and I connect to the server
and I say hey I would like to upload
this file please and normally that would
mean sigh hey here comes the whole file
right here I'm streaming the whole thing
to you right that means that the server
needs to read the file into memory and
and use a bunch of RAM and then take
that the file that has received and send
it to storage
you have to shuffle those bits instead
what you could do is that the server
will validate the request and say ok I
see you want to send me a file I'm going
to send you a URL with a sass key so
that you can do with that file as you
please here's the the place I want you
to store your file the client can then
send data into Azure storage direct and
yes you can do that from the browser
because the ash restore egde support
supports course who knows what courses
can you what's the abbreviation stand
for any for the day so many I I had to
look it up cross-origin resource sharing
right and you can meet means that you
can share resources across domains from
your client the browser won't say oh no
you configure a sure storage with the
right URL and stuff and it will accept
incoming requests from across another
domain so storage then and when you the
file is uploaded directly from the
client into Azure storage well Storage
has the ability today to send events so
when a new file appears it can connect
to the event grid which is another
service in Azure and say hey new file
and that can call into an azure function
I can call into your code and you can do
whatever you need to do with the file to
process it and rather than now sending
you know half a gigabyte of file into
the service
it goes to storage which is so powerful
when you think about it the other way
around
download a file the client asks for a
file through the API
server authenticates logs counts how
many requests and so forth and returned
and then a response with 302 found it
doesn't respond with redirect to another
place or something like that 302 found
is a valid HTTP response it says I found
that file for you that you wanted it's
over there
okay so it gives you back a URL with the
sass key which has read access to the
file which is in Azure storage and all
browsers and everybody knows 302 found
it's cool you gave me back this
directions right here's the key to get
it and here's the directions it's over
there I'll go and download it from there
so now we're downloading the file
directly from storage rather than
actually reading it into the service
into the API and returning it down to
the client it's a massive change and
I've never so far come to a customer
that has implemented something that
shuffles files that has implemented that
never okay so it's rare but it happens
that that you can do this and it's a
great pattern to know about because that
saves you from running large machines in
your service that has to have a lot of
RAM because they're shuffling files
super-good we have some time remaining
which is cool so I thought I'd go over
some sort of more lofty goals it's not a
play on lofty soft or anything but a
some more lofty go some more
like what are you thinking about when
you want to do the cloud thingy right
what is it that you need to focus on
these things are give you a good map if
you focus on these things and and most
of them are also of course very
important for any other application as
well so they're not exclusive to the
cloud in any way shape or form but this
gives you a really good set of
directions the manageability part is how
you understand the health and
performance of your deployed service of
scale remember monitoring yes you have
to understand and be able to manage it
otherwise you will wind up
more instances paying more money just to
have your application run satisfactory
for your customers and which is
ineffective for you the throughput is of
course extremely important because this
is about how to increase you know
operations transaction service calls
whatever number it is that you need to
count to reduce through your system and
then reduce contention if you can if you
can make that happen you can be more
effective then you can of course be able
to optimize your resources right the
density is closely related to the
throughput in this case because how can
you enable efficient software systems on
as few resources as possible while you
are maintaining your high availability
and reliability and your users are are
satisfied this is something you need to
think about and focus on with throughput
and density so that you're able to run
the service on as few resources as
possible because when customers are
complaining and you really can't find
right now anyway you haven't yet found
what the problem is well everybody does
is up the number of instances will give
it more power more power Scotty right
we'll just burn through that money not a
good thing to do in the long term maybe
necessary in the short run the
availability of course is extremely
important that I am going to continue to
talk about that right after this list
actually how to diminish the impact of
failures and survive in failure modes
and still give a great user experience
the reason why this is important in the
cloud is that you are using somebody
else's service all the time right if
you're using sequel database that's a
service hosted by your cloud service
provider Microsoft may be right there
hosting it and running it for you and it
will run they have an SLA with what is
it three nines and a five or something
it will run almost all the time you know
every so often maybe there's a hiccup
and your code needs to be responsive to
that it needs to understand this if it
doesn't you're gonna wind up in lots of
problems but it this is different from
before right when you hosted your
service yourselves
you had a server rack in the server room
right you had an app server rack there
with a little label it says apps and
then you had an underneath but just
immediately underneath there there was a
different rack and said sequel server
right you had a little name that was
smart
the sequel server right you cared for
those servers and you loved them but the
point here is you had a piece of cable
this long right that goes from one rack
to the other that was like that was the
network right that was how difficult and
complicated that was you had a hundred
percent you know control of this
environment you don't live there anymore
when you're in the cloud you're using
services hosted by someone else
extremely important to think about this
and then the latency of course how do I
reduce the time I wait on and wait for
individual operations and service calls
how do I make it faster well there's a
synchrony for that so these sort of
values if you will are things that I try
to actively engage with my customers and
say are we thinking about these things
because really important as an example
of this how to build a composable system
because that seems to be all the rage
now you know micro services and all
these things a really good friend of
mine made a great quote
he's from New Zealand so you'll have to
excuse him but he said building
applications today
it's becoming less about building
applications and more about using
existing services to bolt applications
together and it kind of speaks to what I
said before if you if something you need
to build your application is already
built you can spend a lot of time
building it yourself or you could just
use the service right that's no you have
to pay for that service sure but what
does it actually cost to build it
yourself and maintain it and all that
stuff do you have is it your business to
build a service bus or do you have to
use a service bus for your business like
you have to think about that I'm sure
everyone here can build a service bus
give me enough time and money right but
it's already built you wouldn't go today
and say hey you know what I have this
thought
I'm not really happy with our email
system so I'm gonna build a new email
server right I'm gonna build a new email
service right prove it do that
it's called Office 365 or in Google Apps
for your domain nobody does that
and so obviously you should have the
same approach so a best practice here is
in this scenario is that you must code
asynchronously and you must handle
subsystem failures which means that you
must async await you have to so many
times do I come in and say yeah we
migrated this thing to the cloud and we
know it's not doing really well right
now it's a little bit you know
unreliable and you go and check the code
and sure enough it's the old code which
doesn't do async await okay so you know
2016 called right I don't know what to
say it means that you must retry when
you use services and this is a this is a
retry pattern from Microsoft that they
have listed and it's an extremely
important one and actually odds are
really good that you're doing it by
chance you're using something like
entity framework or one of the SDKs to
communicate with - your store intro
similar they have default retry built in
but you can configure it yourselves and
you probably should figure out and
understand exactly how it does retries
so here's the logic behind it if you
send a request to a service you know
99.99 five times out of all of times
it's going to do exactly what it's
supposed to do and then you know that
one time or whatever that is
it's gonna respond and what do you do
you wait a little then you try again and
then maybe you try again and now we've
tried three times and that's actually
quite a long time so who's ever waiting
for that to complete is somebody who's
now getting a little bit impatient
that's why we have async await it needs
to be able to do something else while
waiting anyway maybe it returns sorry
can't fill this request right now at
that point you have to have your code
respond to contingencies what happens
the service that you're depending on
isn't responding the way it should do
you throw a yellow screen of death at
your user no you don't you have to like
code for that and you know I know users
hate to get that message sorry couldn't
save your profile right now you'll have
to try again later they hate it but what
do they hate more yellow screen of death
right so your code has to be sensitive I
which problem should probably say to the
fact that contingencies happens so you
need to code defensively you need to
know that things will fail not you know
it's not a matter of if they will fail
it's a matter of time they will fail at
some point and then you always need to
do a lot of tracing when you do that so
you have to have that monitoring in
there as well you have to have traces so
that when something retries a lot maybe
that's something that you want to be
alerted on right maybe you want to know
normally there are no retries everything
works everything is good the response
time it's good and then if there is an
issue you'll maybe measure to see well
all of a sudden the API is really slow
wonder why it's so slow well then you'd
like to know why and the reason might be
that there all of a sudden the
underlying service nothing you did the
service that you depend on is slow and
it's not responding as it should so
there's a bunch of retries well maybe
you want to know that so that's
important to do we only have a few
minutes remaining I'm happy that I made
it so far I have lots more to talk my
god we could talk all week we could talk
all week but we're not gonna do that
because beer so I have a bit of a quick
wrap-up but first I'd like to ask are
there any any questions at all have I
made myself understood or you know it's
the thing that I'm saying is it clear if
you have any questions thoughts you're
thinking beer
that's okay yes Oh alternatives to
monitoring so I don't have the luxury of
saying oh you should only use Azure or
influencing my customers in any way I
have customers using all kinds of
logging but the thing that I can say
many of these products are fantastic
right I love them and it's not a problem
it's not about which one to use it's the
fact that they are using one which is
good you know and and some of them do
not I have one of the examples that I
have here in my deck actually is it's
about the customer that is actually
logging to data bases and it's like yeah
there's been so many issues with that
you cannot believe so they used to log
two databases before and then they
migrated to the cloud and built this
multi-tenancy service instead and now
they're logging two databases still it's
just a mess so the point is you should
use whichever one you like whichever
tickles your fancy floats your goat and
so forth use whichever one is good for
you but it has to be one which you know
pulls the data out and puts it in a
service and indexes for you and gives
you alert capabilities and all these
things as to have these nice features
because then you can really fully take
advantage of it and then you use
whichever one you like I know I sound
like a Microsoft salesman sometimes and
so yeah anyway any additional questions
good good question yes billing
monitoring oh my gosh that's a whole
topic of its own we'll talk about that
over beers we have I can give you a
short response yes there is I have a
whole workshop that talks about these
things so what you do is that you you
tag your resources in Azure with tags
and then these tags will flow all the
way through to the bill and there are
services that you could use to read this
and give you nice pie charts and things
you could use power bi for that so yes
definitely to be able to answer the
question how much is development costing
how much is QA costing how much is
production in the u.s. costing and how
much is production in Australia costing
to be able to split and divide and how
much is this customer costing us all
these things you can definitely get that
the the data is there there's actually
two api's and I'm gonna stop ranting
about it but there's actually two AP is
one is the consumption ap I was gonna
tell you exactly how much you have
consumed the other one is the rate card
API which you can call into and say okay
I have consumed an hour of you know
sequin database what and I have this
subscription what does that cost and
basically you could do it yourself but
again don't do that it's been built so
yeah that's a great question and and you
know when when the bean counters come
running saying hey the azure bill keeps
going up it's more and more expensive
how can you motivate and tell it you
need to be prepared for that it's gonna
happen and there's ways to do it yes I
think we're actually coming to a close
here now so I'm gonna give you those two
those are the locations you've probably
been there already but it's it's worth
going in there and spending time read
through the pattern is just once and
then the architecture Center has so much
architecture oh my gosh so many examples
of building different things I think
they've done a really good job here
these are links to a sure documentation
and if you need to learn about you know
there's a hundred and fifty services and
a sure if you need to learn about them
they also have this one additionally the
Microsoft at home
assure essentials bite-sized training
right so it's small it's like it's it's
like an hour or something it's very very
condensed so you can learn about various
services if you have an inkling that
maybe this one is something we need you
check it out in the architecture Center
and say hey we maybe you need to use
service pass we've never done that odds
are really good that there's a naturist
seneschal for service passing you can go
at least get a baseline understanding
about it
so people friends in the cloud you pay
for what you use in the cloud effective
architectures take full advantage of the
multitude of services and in the cloud
your code needs to work when somebody
else's service
not I'm gonna leave you with a nice
picture here the this is an anti-pattern
that I have sort of dreamt together
myself this is of course Wiley coyote
but the anti-pattern is almost flying in
the clouds okay so what does that mean
it means that you don't have to take
everything you haven't put it in the
cloud you don't but if you have it on
premise and you say we're migrating this
to the cloud and then you start
migrating stuff you have new customers
coming in and they may use the cloud
version but you still have your old
customers and they're using the one on
premise and you know you don't want to
upset your old customers because they
were currently paying for the old a new
development you're doing with the cloud
and the longer you stay in this limbo
situation the more assured you can be
that you will fall flat on your face so
that's that's the final words that I
have for you think about that try to
actually if you're migrating something
to the cloud actually get it done finish
it at some point tell the customers you
have them on the ground on-premise tell
them no you must now move to the cloud
this is it so those were my final words
thank you very much for your attention
in case you want to have a workshop
there's one that you could get me to
come in and deliver to you the 2-day
workshop about how to become a wizard of
managering managing Azure resources
thank you for attention
go and have beer thank you very much
[Applause]